hey guys it's justine and i am so
excited because i just got this massive
delivery of a new traeger timberline xl
grill i have been working on redoing my
patio and when you see the before and
after it's been a pretty extensive
makeover and this is the final piece in
the patio makeover that i was waiting
for and it's here and now it's time to
set it up the last time i did an
unboxing it was for my parents we got
them one of the traeger girls so now i'm
so excited i have one of my very own so
the unboxing process
is
well we've got a very big box so let's
let's do it here we go
yeah we're moving and grooving now
like these are holding this whole box
together
like it's pretty much together
is it the right way oh yeah it is the
right way oh this is exciting wow it's
beautiful where are those instructions
at
are you in there i bet they're in here
oh more things i was just looking around
for somebody else to put this together
but it's me and jake this is it we we
don't have anyone else
nice love to see it love it
oh
oh i hope these are just empty boxes
these are not empty boxes there are in
fact
items inside
the wheels are
here start your journey here i took
another path on my journey so um if
you're on the same journey that i'm on
you might want to open the box that was
on the top first the first thing that we
have to do is tip this over so that we
put the wheels on it and this is where
i'm going to need some assistance jake
please
ah shoot your fingers watch your
thingies
they are number
or letter b
[Music]
look at that
this looks right right no it's upside
down yep it is
i we're technically like almost done
[Music]
and if that's the case then these are
the two missing screws
that i need we've got some accessories
i'm so excited because there's so many
different things that you can get for
this we're still building but all that's
left now are the accessories and to get
it all set up on wi-fi so i'm so excited
to actually start grilling i thought i
was gonna be able to grill tonight but
i'm getting tired so tomorrow will be
the big grill out day i've invited some
of my friends over and they're going to
enjoy my cooking well i'm going to i'm
going to make them enjoy it so it's all
put together
i'm going to do all of the setup process
get this hooked up to my phone get it
connected to wi-fi and do the cleaning
process so tomorrow it'll be time to
grill i'm so excited do you like steak
uh do you like burgers i do do you like
chicken i do like beef yeah great
because that's what's on the menu this
is the newest traeger model that is more
versatile and convenient than the
previous models it comes with meter
wireless probes and an outdoor induction
cooktop so you won't have to go inside
to use a stove top it has configurable
storage and accessories with easy
cleanup cutting board 22 pound stay dry
pellet bin a new grease management
system that collects grease and ash a
grilling lights and even more grilling
surface than ever before it is an
exciting day it's grill day and the meat
cave my friends is all set up this
morning the first thing that i did was
get it all ready i did the seasoning and
i've almost tripped on my wood pallets
which is incredible because i already
have one of the bags inside of here
which is where you put the pellets and
that's what actually fires this grill
good morning it's day of the big grill
out and i have to season the grill i'm
getting everything prepped i just woke
up but i want to get this seasoned and
get everything all clean so i can start
prepping so the first thing it's telling
me to do is add the pellets so let's do
it
[Music]
ignite my grill
another thing that i love so much about
this type of grill is you can use it not
only to grill but you can use it for
smoking and baking like you can actually
make muffins there's recipes inside of
the app that shows you all of these
things that you can make and i am by no
means a grilling or cooking expert and
if you're new on my channel here well go
watch some of my old cooking videos
but the thing that i love so much about
this is traeger has a ton of educational
resources in their app they have traeger
tv so i can go and watch all sorts of
recipes get inspiration and even go
through and this will give you
step-by-step recipes of all sorts of
different things like this week their
recipes they have a moroccan spiced
roast chicken red curry salmon and a
baked halibut sandwich with smoked
tartar sauce
wow that sounds incredible also
something cool about traeger is they
have a ton of accessories and they also
have some spices and some sauces
this is the traeger q barbecue sauce and
we actually went out and got this this
morning we did an online order at a
local retailer these i found all at ace
hardware and ordered them online and
jake who's behind the camera here he
picked them up and brought them here for
us to
start our grilling process i don't even
remember what i bought i just kind of
went to whole foods and was like burgers
steaks kebabs yes please also excited to
cook some vegetables this is a nice
little traeger vegetable tray that we
got with the grill this is really cool
this is the induction stovetop so it's a
little accessory that just connects to
the grill not only does it connect
wirelessly through bluetooth but it also
connects with the power to the grille so
you don't have to have any additional
power accessories and this is great
because if you do want to make something
on the stovetop a lot of times you'd
have to go back inside but now you don't
have to because it is right here next to
your grill i just love that everything
works together and it's just so
convenient i can't wait to get cooking
another thing that i love so much are
these little pop and lock accessories so
these are just like these little hooks
that you can get and those just snap
right
into place and over here is this little
roll
bar so you can put paper towel they also
have some trigger meat paper wraps that
you can get i decided to put some foil
here because i have a feeling that we're
gonna need some foil for all of the
things that we're making today i love
this tray this just lifts up
and it folds down but this is another
one of the pop and lock accessories that
just goes right on this little ledge
right there these are the bluetooth meat
thermometers i already have them
connected to the grill it's so easy you
just go in and you add accessories here
on the lcd oh let me just
find a new home for them maybe here
on these beautiful
wooden shelving i love this color
combination too like this black and this
light brown
love that you know what i can do i can
put these in here look at this
a perfect fit i love that okay check
this out this is where the pellets go
and you just dump those in there there's
also a pellet sensor so you'll be able
to know if this is running low and one
of the notes that they have been very
adamant about is making sure that you
don't leave these in here for a long
amount of time if you're not going to be
using them that could affect the pellets
ability to help you grill to perfection
definitely want to keep those away from
humidity which
links us under here we've got this
little container
which
we can put all of our pellets in
when we're not using them this is also
great because they've got little
stickers they have tons of different
types of flavors the one that we're
using now is the natural flavored
hardwood and they have these little
icons right here that show you what it's
recommended for and thankfully this one
is good with anything
which is great because we are making a
wide variety of things today we gotta
start doing some kitchen prep also while
shooting this video the fire pit that i
got which was basically like the two
last parts that i needed for this patio
redo was the grill
and
the fire pit and it's here so my
sister's gonna come over help put that
together this is gonna be the best
impromptu grill out that i've ever had
i've never actually had one before so
it's actually my first my first grill
out are you excited oh my god yes this
is cool let's go prep the meat so we've
got all of our things prepared to take
out to the grill we've got burgers
cauliflower steak we've got some beef
kebabs we've got some filets potatoes
we've got some chicken kebabs they still
have to prep so let's get to it
[Applause]
[Music]
food is prepped friends are on their way
the grill is now going to get preheated
and we are about to drop on the meat and
veggies i love this lcd because
basically you can control everything
through here so we just turned and
pressed the dial to set grill
temperatures we're gonna set to 400
ready to ignite oh we have liftoff we
have liftoff make sure to keep your
grates drip tray okay everything is
clean because you're brand new this all
connects to the app so i'm able to keep
an eye on the heat and i can even adjust
things like the temperature so i can
keep it warm or i can even shut it down
so now we wait and i'll go get our
goods
so to show you guys before and after of
this back patio it was full of weeds it
was disgusting it was so terrible and
now this is the transformation it is
finally complete we've got our fire pits
and we've got our grill and i could not
be more excited they did such a great
job they kind of took my vision i wanted
like this rock wall with succulents they
told me that i probably would kill the
succulents in there so we're gonna put
some fake ones in which
i'm a-okay with but we've got some
really cool planters we've got some
plants all around the outer perimeter
but this rock wall was my favorite piece
of it we've got these little market
lights as well that connect to the rock
wall the sun will be going down soon so
you'll be able to see the ambiance now
it is time
to cook
first meat on
wait i need i'm gonna put it over here
because
i want to stick the temperature sensor
in it no we're jamming this in there
when cooking internal temperatures
[Music]
yes
these are jalapeno burgers
[Music]
get ready for
the meat the induction soap is something
i'm so excited to try out i've got my
cast iron pan here
and we are going to cook up the
asparagus so we just put this on and
then we're going to turn it all the way
up to turbo just to kind of get it
started
and you can notice the color change here
that turns orange and it'll show you
where in the heat range you're at of
course i'll just dump them in
i could do these in the grill but for
the sake of
testing purposes we're making use of the
induction stove
[Music]
so we're gonna take our first little
peek see how they're doing oh yeah these
are looking great so everything looks
pretty good we just received the
internal temperature warning on this
steak so we're going to flip them
looking very good okay burgers
you're getting flipped
that looks incredible there's cheese on
it so that's going to be leaking cheese
through the bottom
steaks are done everyone i can't believe
it i cannot i am just as shook as you
grab yourself a plate
[Music]
our first delivery has been made of our
steaks and now i'm gonna test one out
for myself while the burgers and chicken
continue to cook i like mine usually
pretty well done
so this is perfect it's really hot
oh yeah and the rub that we put on this
too
is so good i'm a happy camper
[Music]
looks like our chicken
is also done
time to serve the guests
this has like a chili flake rub on it
let's try this one huh
oh i think i like that one even warm
that's nice yeah
that's really
good you want pieces of chicken kebab i
do yeah hand it out here
that's really it's nice it's on there oh
this is really good yeah yeah big fan
i'll tell you what this trigger key
though look at that
it's like a chicken nugget
[Music]
night
you're allergic to chicken so i folded
the cheese in
so it doesn't drip down there's a little
bit mess here here put it put it in put
it in we're losing we're losing fire yep
put it in put it in there
bye-bye little grilled cheese
jenna doesn't eat meat
so she made herself a grilled cheese the
cauliflower was really good but i just
was still hungry i'm sorry cheese i'm
just gonna push all this stuff off to
the side because now it's time to bake
cookies you can actually use this grill
to bake jenna my dear sister has prepped
us with some cookies that are basically
already made we just kind of pop them on
the pan look they're gluten free too
alrighty look at these cookies oh my god
these look so good it's like okay so
gluten-free will be over here
so one two three
four
five six so we'll do six on the side
let's go put them on the grill it got
dark real quick out there it is time now
cookies are going in close them up
the grilled cheese i think it's ready
yeah look i had to scoot it over because
oops it was going into the chocolate
cookies on the bottom
oh oh nice you wanna bite i've got such
an interesting buffet of meal
really bad oh my god that's actually so
good i didn't put any butter on her
neither
it has like a little smoked flavor from
the the pellets yeah it's quite nice
i was gonna bring tomato soup
next time
same brain
this is actually really good
who would would've thought me
drum roll please
the cookies i think they're done it's
getting so dark out here i can't
actually see these look so good
take a look at those i'm gonna put a
little sea salt on some do you want some
sea salt sure
they actually look really good
i'm pretty impressed well that concludes
the video thank you guys so much for
watching i had so much fun getting a
chance to use this new traeger grill and
i got to make some chocolate chip
cookies let's try them
oh my gosh
it's perfect maddie i would let you try
this but you're a dog and you can't have
chocolate thank you again to traeger for
partnering with me on this video this
was incredible i look forward to doing
some more grilling now that the patio is
finally complete i can't breathe because
i've eaten so much meat
like i'm literally gasping for air
you guys want to get more information
about the timberline xl grill i'll put a
link in the description and i will see
you guys in my next video peace out
oh god jenna you gotta get in on this
cookie action it's very hot it is hot
it's so good yeah it's too hot
you're fine
all right cookies are ready kids come
and get them
get that cookie
[Music]
you